good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast
and happy Thursday hope everybody's
having a blessed day this far you know
there are blessings all around us and
speaking of blessings feel like I'm
about to give a sermon on a Sunday
speaking of blessings there's one right
in front of my very two eyes hello
jacalene hello jacqualine fle blessings
abound hey turo what's going
on I'm just broken ankle no actually the
ankle is at Bay for now motherhood back
my back is
broken listen I understand I'm an ant I
know what it's like you know caring for
these kids it's tough it's tough It's
funny you're a comedian you're really
they don't pay you enough for these
jokes nobody on the planet understands
you better than I
do they don't pay you enough for these
jokes Jackie did you see this SNL kit
that happened over the weekend with Nate
bazy or Bart Gates
um so it's like this skit on a plane
like a woman's giving birth and they
need a doctor and there's no doctor PhD
no no no so there's no doctor and
they're like all right well what's the
second most important job and the whole
skit is like not even about the pregnant
woman it's like arguing which jobs and
Heidi Gardner stands back she's like
well I'm a
mother and everyone's like great great
and then there's like a teacher it's
really funny that is funny yeah said I
I'll have to find it I'll send you a
clip I I don't even know what I would
search SNL plain skit Nate Bart gatesy
who's Nate Bart gatesy such a good
question that's definitely not how you
pronounce his last name he's Big Time
comic Netflix you know podcast all the
things and he hosted SNL for the first
time he's got like a big following so it
was like a big deal oh I'm happy for him
you love to see podc and never heard of
him before you've definitely like seen
his name I I don't know how to pronounce
his last name B Gates see I'm looking
yeah people love him bar baraty yeah
baraty um I'm looking at an image no I
don't know this man well I'm happy great
success isn't that wonderful for him you
just love to see other people out there
living their dreams for real yeah as
long as they're good worthy people with
goodw worthy dreams with good worthy
intentions so we've got a great show
it's Thursday I'm headed to Bravo con
this evening so tomorrow's episode will
be in audio only Extravaganza from Vegas
on East Coast time West Coast time so
bear with me for tomorrow um but we're
just gon to we're going to bang it out
today you know yeah we've got some good
stories new episode of the redheads
dropped it's so funny we recorded it
yesterday and it was just comedy snitch
and I like got into it in the beginning
of the show because she really called me
out for something that I was very aware
of but I didn't know that she was spill
it
cuz she was saying we were all talking
about like our Halloween weekends are
dressing up and how she dressed up as
reputation and how like I didn't comment
on any of her posts and she was like
none of the sisters comment on my post
but you guys comment on each other's ooh
and I yeah but I had a good reason at
first I said I was very like taken aback
that she dressed as reputation in a
custom costume and like never told me
that she was doing that like I knew
about Cosmo and Wanda she wanted to
borrow my dress but like you tell your
sister when you're getting a custom
costume made like what you're being for
Halloween I knew you were being Fran so
then I see these pictures of honestly
like a stranger on my feed and I I I
wasn't prepared enough to have a caption
like a comment for her because I was so
speechless that I was finding out about
this like every other swab on Instagram
sure my reasoning and I I reject the
conclusion she came to that I comment on
everyone's St except for her like [__]
I don't comment on anyone's stuff except
for you and that's cuz like we're we're
building a brand here you know like I
got to be like oh swirly you know like
say something toasty well I also said
when I comment on claudus it's easy
because like we have so many jokes from
the show all I have to say is like get
ugly and get a million likes right so I
reject that I'm really not a big
commenter on things I just I have
thoughts in my head and I don't really
put them into words I just if I had been
prepared and knew she was being
reputation like just would have been in
my head and I would have like known what
to say instead I was I was
speechless yeah okay so she's attacking
all of us on the redheads is what you're
saying yeah but she she wasn't wrong and
then she was like did you even like my
Instagrams and I was like I think so and
I went thankfully I had liked all of
them I'm more likely to leave a like or
a comment on Tik Tok so did you comment
on her Tik Tok I think I did what did
you say I don't remember I just
something about squirreling Instagram is
so mindless like and I'm usually laying
on my side so I just have my one thumb
and just the thumb is scrolling down and
down and down it's not doing a million
things writing comments and
such
yeah but I think we all kind of need to
do better for our younger sister
honestly she wasn't wrong in her
assessment you want me to do better I
want you to educate yourself and do
better [__]
I'm listening and I'm
learning how
frightening so all right I guess we'll
use today's episode as a platform to
apologize tomorrow um we're also going
to use it as a platform to just unwind
just relax just unwind yeah this
podcasting I have to look at it in a
different lens this is my me time yes
podcasting is my hour plus of just me
hanging out with my best
friend talking
laughing your best friend this is my
pocket of peace for the day you know
what I love that for you I feel that way
too cuz Ben actually experienced
something we're always talking about on
Monday at like 5:00 he was set to record
two episodes of the good guys and he had
such a busy stressful day before and he
was just kind of like venting to me how
he wasn't feeling very good and this
good gu G like I wish I didn't have to
do it and he comes back reinvigorated
cooking me dinner so excited and I'm
like oh you you've turned it around he's
like you know the podcasting was so good
for my mental health like I feel so much
better we were cracking up we did such a
good job and I'm like yes that's what
I'm always telling you like you go into
a podcast maybe you know the worries of
the world the worries of your day are
weighing heavy on your shoulders then
you sit down with your friend and you
just Giggle and really what's better
than that so true but you have to be in
the right podcast for you cuz I feel
like other people's podcasts are
Dreadful no I'm in a bad mood after I
record someone else's podcast or good
mood if it's a good podcast but like
some people really just do Dreadful
content about Dreadful topics talking to
Dreadful people not us no you're going
to you're going to leave here looking
like this and not the good guys no they
are the good guys for a reason I'm anti-
dreadfulness um also speaking of things
that are not Dreadful up on the patreon
now my Heidi clume Halloween Vlog gwm
it's a get ready with me it's behind the
scenes of the party it's the after party
we've got some celeb cameos in there
Taylor lner's in there so it's really
good stuff it's at patreon.com toast
it's just 30 minutes of good old fashion
fun I'm so excited to watch I didn't get
a chance to because I was editing
redheads as I previously mentioned check
us out um not you're trying to like
promote redheads when I'm trying to
promote my Vlog just like I'm just
trying to continuously promote and the
promotion ever sleeps and I can you're
like stepping on my promotion I can
weave my promotion into yours and then
Circle back back to your promotion which
was that I'm really excited to watch
Shark Boy and Lava Girl Meet their hero
yeah it's all in there it's a fabulous
Vlog first of the month never a bad time
to become a patreon member patreon.com
toast $7.99 gets you five extra episodes
a month their Vlogs they podcast they
video podcast they're all different
types of content we've got friends
family joining us Dana was just on it
Ben is always on and we've always got
people coming through coming in coming
out you don't want to miss it $7.99 and
with inflation that's like that's like
what $2 used to be you know
so true no actually $77.99 now was
probably like
$4 when we started
patreon yeah yeah I was thinking of it
the other way like what would $799 be
now like $12 13 yeah yeah and we think
about us like we respect the economy but
we respect the towers more so we haven't
raised the price yeah even though you
know would be nice but we we won't we
won't we won't but it would be
nice um so before we get into the
stories did you watch any of the shows
that were on TV last night I did not I
know Beverly Hills was on it was on I
completely forgot I watched Gossip Girl
I'm on like episode 8 every 30 seconds
in the show I literally turned to Ben
I'm like these people are literally 14
it's so they're like going to butter
okay so in the episode we watched last
night Blair had her big sleepover Serena
couldn't come so they let Jenny come
yeah and Jenny's 14 and first it's just
a sleepover and then they end up at a
club and they're like playing truth or
dare making out with like 40-year-old
Wall Street
um it's disgusting like it's not okay in
any
way yeah do you think you're going to
finish with the show or stick with it no
we are hating it like for real watch I
told you a few good things to watch I
think I'm hating it because I'm such a
strong moral compass for real no and
because it's like not as you remember it
like you remembered it like they were
older than you and it was like you were
looking up to them now you're looking
down on them like you should just let it
remain in your memory pristine as it was
oh and last night's episode Jessica not
Jessica that's her name in real life
Vanessa made her first appearance I
totally forgot about her character then
I remembered all the Dreadful characters
who come through like Georgina I'm
really not interested in reliving the
Georgina years you're about to hit
Georgina if you don't stop really I
thought it was like season 3 no she
comes in soon I rewatch season one she's
coming any minute now for the
SATs for the SATs like what yeah she
comes like when Serena is supposed to
take her SATs and then SP alert like
Sabrina doesn't make it cuz Regina
[__] drugs her and you just said
Sabrina doesn't make it cuz Regina drugs
her like that's what you just said and
you knew what I meant I did and you
knew and I
knew so Chuck hire someone to take
Serena's sat for her yeah I'm not going
to stick with it I not having this
Renaissance that I feel most people have
when they watch Gossip Girl sorry to be
such a naysayer but just further proves
I'm not like other girls and I'm
definitely going to get into something
new and to answer your question long
story short no I didn't watch real house
size at Beverly Hills I completely
forgot it was on same maybe I'll watch
it on the plane today to Bravo con that
would be app propo now that I've
finished I had a lot of work to get done
this week but I finished it as of last
night so I can get back to watching
lessons in chemistry which oh that's a
good one was such a good treat I was
really enjoying it so there will be no
TV recap today but that just gives us
more minutes on the Kurds to talk about
ourselves and to be honest I'm really
not upset about it neither am I shall we
get into the stories before we send you
on your bond Voyage to Sin City where
you know what happens in
Vegas stays in Vegas can you say
bonvoyage to someone who's not going on
a
boat or crossing a sea why do I feel
like Bond Voyage has to do with the sea
do you agree I never heard that in my
life but no it's just a Vibe I'm not
saying like cuz Bond Voyage means like
good Voyage [__] but I feel like a it
means good voyage [__] yeah yeah it
does voyage I feel like it just means
safe travels in French not to be
confused with Bon yeah just is sending
someone on a safe journey well yeah I
didn't think it had any Maritime
connections bage tury L Maritime is one
of my favorite words to use and you use
it in everyday life I do it means having
to do with the c
correct wait here someone asked on
Google can you say bon voyage for a
flight okay uh when you want to wish a
safe trip and a good trip to someone or
group of people you can simply add Bon
boyage if a trip involves the road you
can use Bon rout and if it's a flight
it's
bonv I'm not really interested in
learning other French phrases um Boni
and Bon voage are more than enough for
me
okay what's better than like having a
question in your head and then Googling
it and somebody asked that exact same
question on like quora or Yahoo
questions or like Reddit or something
it's the the best yeah it's like I'm not
done Dum dumb yeah you're not done
either I told you guys like it's going
to be a day for me so I hope that you're
able to translate what I'm saying um
should we get a translator we might need
one we might need like captions Asters
beneath me editor's note here's what she
meant she meant dumb she meant
Serena and
Georgina right sorry sorry all right I'm
ready okay wait I just want to say can I
just say one more thing about Voyage
because I just looked at the dictionary
definition it said a long journey
involving travel by sea or in
space
space so like I'm not wrong for my
Association by the way I never thought
you were wrong I'm sure you were right
but it's my level of care like there is
none I'm still going to say it oh for
sure as you should and by the way like
say whatever you want freedom of speech
while you still got it tury l right but
I'm just trying to like scratch this
itch you know I'm trying to assess the
origins of where my associations came
from scratch away girl scratch
away but now that we're done scratching
without further Ado it is time for the
fast five stories that you need to know
and the fast five stories that you need
to know are brought to you by State Farm
the State Farm personal price plan helps
you create an affordable price just for
you the plan's all about being personal
to you and your needs that means you'll
get the coverage you want want a policy
that helps cover what's important to you
and an affordable price just for you
because after all life is just better
when you can personalize your
experiences think about it like this
from your go-to coffee order to your
favorite pair of sweatpants we know you
love to personalize your entire day just
like we do I mean what's more personal
than coffee took me about a year to
figure out I just like the stuff from
the grocery store what's more personal
than clothing I mean these jeans a life
time of experience to to land myself in
these jeans everything is so personal
and what's more personal than Insurance
honestly nothing and it should be that
way cuz take Jax and I two more similar
girls you never met but our insurance
needs are quite different Les we not
forget Jackie lives in another state
let's me not forget Jackie's a homeowner
let's me not forget Jackie has not one
car but two and one of them is electric
what does that mean for her insurance
needs well State Farm has got her
covered personalization just makes
everything better and State Farm
believes that insurance should work the
same so your plan your coverage your
selections are all personalized by
you like a good neighbor stay Farm is
there also I have a feeling I believe
I'll be meeting Jake from State Farm
this weekend so celeb sighting I'm
charging my camera like I'm ready I'm
excited for you call or go to
statefarm.com today prices vary by state
options selected by customer
availability and eligibility may vary
like a good neighbor State Farm is there
today's episode is also brought to you
by the game time app you shouldn't have
to worry when you buy tickets to your
next you shouldn't have to worry when
you buy tickets to your next big event
game time is the fast and easy way to
buy tickets for all the sports music
comedy and theater events near you with
killer last minute deals all in prices
views from your seats and the best price
guad uned game time makes the guest work
takes the guesswork out of buying
tickets not me botching this ad I guess
I'm the only not the only one who not
okay game time is the only ticketing app
that gives you complete peace of mind
with your purchase see the view from
your seats before you buy you know
exactly what to expect when when
arriving they're all in pricing shows
you your total upfront so you know what
you're getting and how great of a deal
you're getting before you check out you
can buy tickets within seconds in in the
app with just two Taps so game time has
deals on tickets right up to the start
of the event and even an hour after it
starts it's the place to find last
minute deals with Zone deals you'll be
able to pick the section and game time
will pick the ceas for you for Big Time
Savings now the best part is the game
time guad that means you'll always get
the best price if you find tickets in
the same section and row for Less game
time will credit you 110% of the
difference so take the guesswork out of
buying tickets with Game Time download
the game time app create an account and
use code toast for for $20 off your
first purchase terms apply again create
an account and redeem code t o a s for
$20 off download game time today last
minute tickets lowest price guad oned we
live in an age where getting tickets is
one of the most stressful things ever
and Game Time understands how
unacceptable that is and they're taking
the stress out of it so download the
game time app use code toast for $20 off
your purchase today's episode is also
brought to you by sax.com we are always
doing our best when it comes to looking
fabulous on the podcast and you know
some people call us fashionistas not a
lot but we call ourselves sax andas
sometimes our pajama uniforms and our
sweatshirts need a little bit of an
upgrade and that's why we love shopping
at sax.com for everything from looks for
the podcast to gno outfits and more and
in this year of yes I need luk I need
luk Galore I shopped on sax.com for my
Lukes for bravocon you guys just wait I
think you're going to be really
impressed you're going to like what you
see I guarantee it um and what's so
great about shopping at sax.com is the
way it's so customizable so if you're
going there for work looks you're going
there for vacation looks you're going to
a festival like whatever you're looking
for Holiday looks they have an edit they
have a a category for you you don't have
to search through hundreds of pages they
will make it super easy whether you're
going for a cozy Vibe a more elevated
look they've got it all at sax.com and
you can even shop by your star sign or
by your situation so you can find the
perfect Revenge dress from Brands like
Christopher esber cult Gaia that's
another reason I love shopping at
sex.com they like know all the cool
designers before everybody else does so
you can start shopping from cool
designers and then like months later
everybody's like oh my God you were
wearing cult guy like yeah cuz I'm cool
and I'm a sax anista that's what people
don't understand so discover new ways to
shop for everything every day at
saks.com that's saks.com whatever you're
looking for whatever the occasion
holiday season around the corner going
on vacation girl go to sax.com they've
got you covered saks.com thank you L
you're you're welcome lja our first
story a little vehicular news sucession
star Alan Rock who plays Conor Roy Roy
crashes his truck into an La Pizzeria
Alan Ruck Connor Roy was reportedly
involved in a four vehicle collision in
Hollywood on Tuesday that resulted in
his truck crashing into a pizzeria the
vehicular accident involving Ruck
occurred around 9:00 p.m. at rafal's
Pizza near the intersection of laa
Avenue in Hollywood Boulevard according
to TMZ who was the first to report the
news of ru's involvement spokesperson
for the LAPD confirmed the details of
the crash to People magazine but could
not identify Ruck as one of the drivers
his rep did not immediately respond to a
quest request for comment there were no
significant injuries in the crash aside
from one 40-year-old woman complaining
of pain to her arms it is unclear at the
moment if this was uh a DUI or whether a
sobriety check occurred the police
report is still
pending uh and he did remain at the
scene um after the Collision I saw the
video of his truck like halfway through
a pizzeria it was like a of concrete
Pizzeria this wasn't just like a a pizza
stand like it was a big ass building
like a building I'm so glad everyone's
okay I'm curious if there's any
nefarious Behavior involved because I've
just been feeling like this is a trend
where celebrities cars end up in in
buildings you know Pete Davidson with
the with the home uh and it needs to
stop yeah I feel like how does this
happen without something or some actor
not this actor an actor in the event
acting
nefariously right it's like a crazy
thing for your car to end up in a
pizzeria yeah that just doesn't happen
every day it certainly does not so I
hope they get to the bottom of this I
also am glad everyone's okay but this is
serious stuff no and this story made me
realize I did not know Connor Roy's name
cuz I'm like who is Alan Rock and then I
looked him up and they were like Ferris
buer so then I realized it was Connor
Ferris bu yeah that's another fun fact
he was the friend when I put that that
together I was absolutely shocked and of
course everybody I shared it on my
Instagram I was like did you guys know
that Connor Roy from succession is the
friend with the red car in Ferris sper
and everybody was like you didn't know
that no I didn't [__] know that okay
she has a life she has a business she's
not keeping tabs on all things all the
time I'm an aunt I'm a dog Mom I'm a
sister I'm a friend I'm a lover like my
God sorry I didn't know one thing not
the lover I am a
lover okay Carrie Bradshaw lover okay I
agree Carrie Bradshaw ruined the word
lover with that episode I've taken
sniffs perfume sample a lover ruined
Taylor Swift made it a little bit better
but when I think when I always say I'm
like a sister a friend a lover I think
of the song does to me by Luke Holmes oh
I'm a hell of a lover a damn good
brother and I wear this heart on my
sleeve that's what I think of so there
are people in popular culture on undoing
what Sarah Jessica Parker diding the
damage and to Luke Holmes and Taylor
Swift I am grateful yeah I agree I've
taken a lava I'm going to take my
headphones off if you keep doing that
okay sorry I'm done um I I think the
tailor one for me made an impact made an
impact left an indelible Mark it's
annoying when people in popular culture
ruin words yeah it happens all the time
but sometimes they make words too so
true like sometimes you can't say a
random word without like quoting the
movie quote let me think like what I
mean like everything for us for us yeah
but like certain movies like Mean Girls
is
like I'd rather see you out there
shaking that thing but you said one word
yeah okay well what's a word
help if you want to do mean girls no or
any movie that we love one word that
changed the way we pronounce things I
mean yet
ugly Julie Julie cork Julie Corky did
you see the girl who dressed up as Julie
Corky for Halloween she wore like that
sparkly red dress that like her and her
friends you know ripped apart I'm
obsessed and a little ass Scott like a
sexy little scarf that she had to steal
from the guy best costume ever except
that it should be a group costume and
you got all the girls involved shot
yany yeah cuz I just wear denim jacket
and my hair and a bun yeah um so glad
for alen rck everyone's doing okay um by
the way do we have an update on Matthew
Perry's um
as a story no so like the updates are
really leaning towards like nothing
nefarious which is
so disturbing but did something he
drowned but did did he have like a
condition that no now they're looking
into like burglaries in the neighborhood
like really makes me feel like really
bad about what I said on Monday like I
was so wrong and so dumb so I really
wanted to apologize again but it's like
saying that there was like like some
some some people say like he could have
got overheated and fainted in the
jacuzzi like he really shouldn't be in a
Jacuzzi alone and for a long period of
time jacuzzi are like low-key dangerous
but they're like all like a lot of signs
are pointing to like just like kind of a
mystical or maybe like something um like
a
natural healthwise and that caused him
to like but that just makes it so much
sadder after all he'd been through yeah
all he accomplished all he overcame
yeah it's very sad that is sad are you
ready for our next story yeah I don't
know how I want to order them today go
your gut I'm kind of wanting to shake
things up they're all pretty oh here's
another thing we another word we can't
say shake things up Shake It Up Chicago
oh yeah yeah yeah okay next story Kylie
Jenner and Timothy shalam laughed
together at the Wall Street Journal
magazine innovators award so Kylie last
night was in New York City for the wsj
magazine innovators award where she got
an award for
innovating um Timothy was also there
they walked the carpet separately but
then inside they
laughed oh did they live and love as
well it but definitely they were living
as they were alive I want to speculate
and say they loved because I agree
they're doing a lot together and I think
they're in love and then we have
confirmation that they they yeah I think
it's safe to say that they in fact live
laugh loved yeah it's hearsay though
yeah no and we would never put something
out on the show that wasn't completely
verified and confirmed by all of our
sources so I retract but we're certainly
two out of the three living and laughing
um this is cute also I feel like the kai
launch came and
went yeah I was actually checking it out
last night I I there's stuff still
available on this site I watched her do
like a haul of like trying stuff on the
stuff is really she looks really nice in
it it's very good-looking stuff it's not
for my current ERA so I'm going to have
to bow out uh bow out old friend bow out
but it looks like a lovely pieces of
clothing I think that's interesting that
it didn't sell out I feel like that
probably wasn't the goal but it has half
million followers on Instagram already
I'm sure it did
well you didn't want to get a pair of
leather pants I actually have a pair of
leather pants from Spanx that I love but
are they like lowrise bell bottoms no
and that's why I love them they're
actually high-rise bell bottoms you
should get that dress that was in her
thing you wear similar one this weekend
yeah and I have it right and it was like
a dollar right the
coat no I'm not a big trench
girl oh we'll play we'll be playing this
back in a year
totally a trench is a nice look tury L
not saying you should get that one not
saying you should get that one cuz that
one like you have to be Kylie really to
pull off I can tell you actually my
problem with trench coats and like coats
like
that well there's two different trenches
and coats like that like aren't no but I
mean like midlength you know coats that
are like like they look like a dress
almost and they're so stylish and
everybody looks so fabulous in them okay
like it's your coat so it's meant to be
taken off okay and so it's really the
whole look a lot of
times well you could also dress yourself
underneath in an outfit that you feel
confident in I know but who has time to
wear like a fabulous under outfit and
outer outfit it's one or the other but
that's the beauty of the Cod it's like
you throw it on and you just look
fabulous but you didn't have to take any
time or effort except once you take it
off once you take it off you don't look
fabulous you just made my point no but
you get dressed in whatever fabulous
wees you would
wear I mean this scenario just assumes I
have so many fabulous wees outerwear and
underwear no but any outfit that you
would wear what you're wearing today so
so cute oh and by the way those types of
coats don't keep you warm do you know
how [__] cold it is today okay yeah
they're not winter coats they're not
winter coats so it's like there's a
3-week period where you could wear a
coat like that on both ends of the
seasons okay so six
weeks and then there's those you know
nice days in the winter cold days in the
spring yeah oh that another two weeks
it's so cold it's it's that time of year
where like you walk to work and the
makeup under your nose is completely
gone because you have snot everywhere
what's the temperature it says it's
40° it feels I swear to God like 17 I
was I was not okay I wear my puffer I'm
freezing yeah that's time days like
today mornings like today I'm happy for
you no I'm jealous of you I like that no
it's really
unbearable it didn't even start yet
that's what I'm saying that's like a
pleasant Winter's day no but the thing
is this is my first winter with like
less meat on my bones and that's
definitely a temperature Factor like you
need to get a better coat I mean I've
been telling you this for years what
puffer did you wear Monclair I don't
think they make a better puffer [__] no
they don't when did you get a
Monclair yeah I got a Monclair yeah
when I got a
Monclair mardia mon claria did you spill
your coffee cuz you got so excited about
mon claria I tipped my coffee but it did
not spill cheers ja cheers to another
great episode of the toast cheers M
claria thanks like I need to have better
nicknames like for you because you
always say thanks leria and I'm always
like you're
welome
okay but I'm not the nickname girl you
are and you really can't make a nickname
for yourself I need to meet a friend
named
Jackie so that I can come up with
nicknames for the name Jackie ja fle
isn't a bad nickname no no it's just
like not relevant it's not a nickname
it's just something from a movie another
thing we can't say the same trills
trills are you ready for our next story
what number three yes Lori Laughlin and
her look like daughter Olivia Jade are
the perfect pair in a new Steve Madden
campaign four years after the College
admission Scandal so Lori Laughlin and
her mini daughter Olivia Jade are the
new faces of the SHO brand Steve Madden
the Full House Alum joined her youngest
daughter in the ad four years after the
College admission Scandal the actress
shares both Olivia and her elest
daughters Isabella with her husband
fashion designer masim moia nuli in the
pictures they are all smiles in all all
about town the shoes are looking good
the girls are looking good these are
really cute pictures very well styled
cute shoes cute girls um obsessed I am
so here for the
Renaissance the Redemption era
the
Resurgence of Lor Lan and Olivia Jade I
feel like Olivia Jade bounced back I
mean she's with Jacob Lor like what more
could a girl ask for but Lor Lan you
know was the one who really took the
brunt of the the public outcry she was
the one who actually went to prison so I
am so here for this in so many
disgusting ways I love these two and I
really like to think like what the world
would have been like had the College
admission Scandal not happened because
Olivia Jade was on her way to taking
over the world yeah she was and even
though like she's boun te and she can do
as she pleases I feel like she doesn't
do that much no I think the
um the experience of going through like
a public Scandal it ain't for the faint
of heart and I actually think it really
um was traumatizing for her and she's
not really interested in being that girl
anymore the girl she once was the girl
who was so susceptible to public
um scrutiny scrutiny thank you and who
like put every aspect of her life online
like that's what it means to be an
influencer or a YouTuber and it's like
no thanks yeah if you don't need to and
she's you know I think like the
definition of a neppo baby she doesn't
need to do that so if you don't need to
you you and you see the bad side of it
you're never going back there yeah I
think also her being in her high-profile
relationship it's like you guys get none
of this how about [__] you all no and it
works for her like I don't think had she
been sharing as much as she was sharing
and by the way when you go through such
public scrutiny everything you've ever
shared comes back to haunt you and use
it against you so I don't think she
could have gotten into such a high
profile relationship if she had been
such a big sharer yeah because
high-profile people aren't into that no
and then she could not share her
relationship but then the fans are like
you're not sharing right no I think the
the comeback for Olivia Jade has been a
very slow roll out I think it's been
very intentional I think it's been very
successful now I think this is her first
time you know really working with a
brand yeah well certainly in like such a
you know big campaign yeah but it's also
just a big campaign in general like even
if she was a working influencer all the
time like to get
a be the face of a shoe brand like
that's big big thing that's different
that's different than than doing like
you know a sponsored YouTube video 100%
I love this I respect this and this is
this is a saga I'm glad we're like done
with you know yeah and it's just it
seems so small now oh my God but that
happens all all the time every scandal
in the moment you're like this is the
biggest thing that's ever happened to
celebrity to Hollywood and then years
later you're like H it wasn't even that
bad no it's weird at the time it was
like the biggest deal ever but now it's
like they were trying to go to college
why no and why were they trying so hard
to get into college no not even that it
was like at the time there were so many
we were extrapolating you know this is a
you know prime example of privilege like
we like we knew it and now it's just
like okay rich people were like being
rich and doing Rich things to get into
college like we knew exactly that that
was happening in the world I maybe some
of us didn't know it was against the law
but like I don't know like the world's
going to turn and rich people going to
do rich things and who cares should have
just gave a library right next time
donate a wing yeah you learn you live
and learn you live and learn are you
ready for our next
story yeah one of the most interesting
things about the College admission
Scandal to me in the case of the
celebrities was how the women took the
fall Felicity Huffman went to prison
that to me is so interesting you like I
hear what you mean like yeah the men
should have stepped up for their women
but like it was their names on the email
no but like everyone's names were on the
email I don't recall William Macy's
names being but the moms being the ones
like helping with the college
applications like that's how the world
works yeah yeah I just find it
interesting
to play on gender
roles okay that's a good that's a that's
a good take on it somebody should write
like a college essay about
[Laughter]
that please don't are you ready for our
next story are you ready no the next
story is brought to you by L'Oreal
bright
reveal this episode is brought to you by
the new L'Oreal Paris bright reveal dark
spot serum and broadspectrum spf50 daily
lotion dark spots game over h dark spots
are one of my least favorite parts of
growing up like ew like after spending
like the summer in the Sun and you know
winding down into fall and noticing like
these things all over my face not here
for it I turn to L'Oreal and so can you
so any sort of act activities you've
been doing in the sun like for me you
know this was my summer of pickle ball
there are consequences for having so
much fun and those consequences are dark
spots but just because summer is over
doesn't mean you need to stop wearing
SPF as well and the SPF broadspectrum 50
daily lotion from L'Oreal is a great
option so so age spots sunspots as well
as acne marks are all visibly fading
once you start using the L'Oreal bright
reveal 12% it has niacinamide Amino
sulfonic and ferulic acid it's the dark
spot serum it's fabulous after 12 weeks
12 weeks there's up to 40% less visible
less visibility on post- acne marks 43%
less visible dark spots and 49% more
even tone um the sunblock is also
fabulous because I feel like a lot of us
aren't wearing sunblock under our
makeup and that's really not a cool
thing to do so you can visibly reduce
the appearance of dark spots and resist
sun-induced signs of aging 100% of dark
spots are intensified by the Sun and 96
96% of women agree that the L'Oreal
bright reveal SPF 50 daily UV lotion
doesn't leave a white cast so discover
the new bright revealed dark spot Duo
visit Target online and in store to buy
yours today today's episode is also
brought to you by the farmer's dog the
results of switching to your your dog
from kibble to Fresh can seem like magic
when a senior dog starts acting like a
puppy again and the pickiest of eaters
can't wait for dinner time you might
think some spells were cast but the
farmer's dog doesn't use any sorcery or
secret ingredients to make their fresh
food they just use science and the
farmer's dog delivers and makes fresh
healthy dog food it's developed by vets
nutritionally balanced and made from
real healthy ingredients to human food
safety conditions it's the best option
for dogs at all life stages because it's
not kibble it's not canned goo it's just
real healthy food traditional dry and
wet dog food options are highly
processed they can use much lower
quality ingredients than they claim to
and they are extremely difficult to
portion accurately the farmer's dog
isn't just fresh higher quality food
they also send the food pre-portioned
specifically for your dog based on their
unique nutritional needs this makes it
easy to help your dog maintain their
ideal weight which is one of the biggest
indicators of a full healthy life dogs
at a healthy weight can live up to 2 and
a half years longer than overweight dogs
a fresh diet has been found to have all
sorts of healthy benefits for Theo once
we switched his breath oh my God was
definitely abnormal before his breath is
is so much better he makes more
consistent normal sized poops his fur is
really shiny his coat is really healthy
so get 50% off your first box of fresh
healthy food at thefarmersdog.com toast
plus you get free shipping only when you
go to thefarmersdog.com toast go to
thefarmersdog.com toast to get 50% off
your first box plus free shipping that's
50%
5 thanks Claud you're wels okay our next
Story the Halloween cancelling are
rolling in we've got our first offender
with um their offensive costume who
shitz Creek star Emily Hamshire
Stevie okay apologizes for dressing as
Johnny Depp and Amber herd for Halloween
she said quote I am deeply ashamed so
her and a friend dressed up as Johnny
and Amber Stevie herself was Johnny and
then the friend who was Amber was
wearing like a peasant blouse and
holding a duty and crying
that's funny um and so she got immediate
and Swift backlash and put out a
statement saying I want to address what
is one of the most thoughtless
insensitive and ignorant things I've
ever done I just want to say it's really
not thoughtless like actually a lot of
thought goes into Halloween costumes you
had to buy a duty yeah and they put
googly eyes on the duty too you had to
Source the duty and the googly eyes and
that seems like a lot of thought went
into it yeah and Stevie looked pretty
like much like Johnny H she said I
stupidly thought it would be funny to
dress as Johnny Depp and Amber Heard I
am deeply sorry and ashamed for putting
something that awful out into the
universe domestic abuse is never ever
funny these are real issues with real
people and I really regret my actions in
the future I will do better I'm so sorry
did she say she's listening and learning
no she didn't it's not a full statement
until you're listening and
learning um I have so many thoughts on
this like first of all I really thought
as a society like we were Beyond like
celebrities like the last one for me
like nothing no celebrity should ever
have done a bad costume and had to
release a statement after Julian Hoff
went in blackface like to me that was
the last one you know like we are beyond
that as a society yeah you think that
like people could get their Halloween
costumes right without like [__] up
and having to apologize without like
being culturally insensitive wearing a
red arm band with the swasa doing
blackface like there are just things you
don't do now this one in particular it's
not as bad as black or Nazi to the those
other ones that are like cultural
appropriation or offensive you know I
think everybody knows about that by now
right this is different everybody knows
you shouldn't dress up as like
Pocahontas like we know this the the
cultural ones right na See's black face
things of that nature
this is a different bucket I agree a new
bucket it's a new bucket where it's just
like out of touch a little bit like it's
not as bad of a crime I agree it
requires a statement I guess um but I
just like I could have told you this you
know
yeah it's just it's funny what people
get in trouble for and what they don't
get in trouble for no but this is also
like an an a big L for someone who I
feel like is
very
um woke yes yeah like she's in the know
about what's going on in the world like
it's not like she lives under a
rock yeah yeah so somebody who's
supposed to be you know sensitive right
somebody who has like their head in the
clouds and is just you know going about
their life I could see them like making
this mistake of course um but it is it's
weird that her her own woke radar didn't
go off on this one and I just have to
say that's just something I see a lot
the people who think they're doing the
most are like secretly the most
problematic Rachel dool yeah
yeah did anybody go as Rachel dozol for
Halloween I'm sure they did maybe not a
celebrity that's a great costume and who
were we talking about no it's not it
requires you to wear black
face okay was Rachel dozol did she ever
wear black face did she like she was
making herself
Tanner
H and then of course you can't talk
about making yourself Tanner without
talking about Len deeps right now she
really was had her you know that scene
in A Walk to Remember when she's got a
leg in Maine and a leg in New York or
whatever the yes lanne had a leg in
spray tan and a leg in black face it's
still very much Up For Debate I don't
think there's been a a conclusion made
about whether she was was officially
doing blackface or she just got a bad
spray town I even though I think we can
all agree it was
blackface but she but she pretty much
got away with it oh 100% and Les we not
forget the
wig yeah it wasn't a but see Luan is
someone who I feel is the opposite of
Emily Hampshire like she Lan has no idea
what goes on in this world like most of
the housewives don't live in this world
head in the clouds that's what we were
saying right
so I could see her intentions being
different than the impact of course
aren't they mostly aren't they usually I
just I didn't think we'd be having this
conversation about Halloween costumes in
202 I really thought we were past this
yeah no it was a shock to me as well to
me there's a Hall of Fame of problematic
Halloween costumes of course juliean
Hoff is the first stop on the Tour
Prince Harry as a Nazi is another stop
on that tour Lisa Rena and Harry Hamlin
are also in that Hall of Fame yes Sid
Vicious who else is in the Hall of Fame
am I forgetting anyone let's Google it
offensive celebrity Halloween costumes
yeah I'd have to be forgetting
some
okay the most controversial Halloween
costumes ever worn by CBS oh there was
that Machine Gun Kelly Megan Fox like uh
religious fetish costume religious I
feel is problematic but people there's
really no outcry against it but like
it's wrong it it is wrong but it like
you know you don't get cancelled for it
you're allowed to like make fun of
religious priest yeah but you shouldn't
dress as a rabbi you shouldn't dress as
a
priest
uh these next ones I don't remember any
backlash for oh Chris Brown dressed up
as a member of the T bond in 2012
wow um that feels definitely
inappropriate yeah feels very unbrand
for Chris Brown and I feel like there
was probably no backlash because like
he's not he was like already cancelled
right right okay keeping going I like
how you put an accent on the Taliban I
think I would say
Taliban it just depends data data
yeah um some of these like I don't
recall them or I don't even know what
they are so right so maybe they're not
in the Hall of Fame if we don't recall
them o Ashley Benson trust Cecil the
lion that doesn't go in the Hall of Fame
that is funny I'm sorry that is funny
but also she's just a lion like who said
she was Cecil right was she walking
around the party saying hi I'm Cecil
maybe like her caption said something
about Cecil but I think it's fine I
think it's fine too and also that's like
in hindsight right it's fine it actually
ages well I guess the Halloween Hall of
Fame is pretty small which is good it is
there's a lot more people on these lists
but I
I'm I'm not oh God the mirror just shut
down my
iPad uh no I don't want accept your
cookies go away um there are other
people on the list but I either don't
know who they are I don't know what
they're being and I'm not to speak on
them okay so Emily I'm sure we'll be
doing better hopefully I look forward to
watching the listening and the learning
are you ready for our fifth and final
story yeah Yellowstone final episodes
are now moved to November 2024 with two
more spin-offs in the works oh my God
1944 and
2024 have been ordered so wait 2024
that'll be the new one when this one
ends when Yellowstone ends they're going
to do like a new show remember with
Matthew mccon and I think that will be
this is my putting all these articles
that we report on every six months
together um 2024 will be like the new
Dutton ERA with Matthew MCC I don't know
why they can't just kill off Kevin CER
and keep going like honestly he's not
even my favorite part of the
show I I would rather they didn't after
now rewatching all of these shows that
like go on a little too long they kill
off Marissa and spoiler and then and
then they try and like make fetch happen
I'd rather it end with dignity honestly
and be like a perfect little gem of a
show like I just got involved you know
and Yellowstone is going a little long
in the tooth now you know I've been
loving the recent episodes just because
it's a comfort show for me but nothing
of import is happening that's true so I
think they should end it I like this
tabularasa 2024 Matthew mccon
speculation see what's in store for the
dutts plus we have
1944 okay but so 2024 though the current
Yellowstone season season takes place in
modern times so can is it safe to assume
that characters from Yellowstone will be
in 2024 I hope and are they going to
have to change the name of the
show with each year that passes no that
was like 1923
1886 yeah but if we're watching 1886
like
1883 it's you know everything could be
happening in 1883 you know yeah but I
think even if they went into the the
next calendar year it's okay I just want
to say I like the names of the shows
being the year but 2024 is like a little
too real and that sounds like a show
about
Mars yeah not about a ranch
no and so we have to wait a whole year
for the final episodes of Yellowstone
when we've already waited a year and a
half yes but that is because one Kevin
cner drama to writer strike oh that's
true so everything is delayed further
yeah
but at least we have lessons in
chemistry and the crown is allegedly
coming out soon yeah we reported that
yeah so things are being released that
were already made they just can't be
promoted oh
yeah yeah that's what I've seen
cool they can't be promoted yet but
maybe sag Afra will strike a deal soon
yeah maybe
maybe not I feel as though I've seen a
lot of rhetoric of people getting like
annoyed with sag I just watched this
video of Renee rap the Halloween thing
really put people over the edge being
she was like we've lost the plot like
you're going to call my kid a scab If he
if he dresses as Woody from o story yeah
I think there's people are really really
ready for the strike to be over yeah
they've they you could say they've lost
the plot you could with the Halloween
thing yeah um and so
sagra do better I hope they're listening
and
learning I don't think they are honestly
I think they're telling everyone else to
listen and learn Jackie you know what
I've actually been meaning to talk to
you about something I really feel like
you haven't been listening and learning
recently you
think oh I'm sorry tury L I'll continue
to not listen and to not learn and
that's what we can come that's what we
could expect from you and that feels I
actually I at my core I'm a listener
yeah and I'm a learner yeah you are and
I absolutely love to educate myself in
all different ways you
do now they doing better that's where I
struggle I guess it's just how do we
Define better whose definition of better
it's subjective it is but I'm doing
better every day I'm growing I do it
every day I'm growing in the evening and
even when we play and when we grow we
love that felt good those were the fast
five stories felt as though you needed
to know them yeah and that's our final
show while I'm in studio This Week final
video show so hope you got a good look
at these mugs yeah just hear it take one
last
look it's giving A Star is
Born just want to get one last look at
you and our episode tomorrow will be
podcast only from bravocon I'm headed to
Vegas so I'm going to hang up with you
ja and head to uh s City what's a song
about Vegas via Las
Vegas Las Vegas vas
viva viva Las
Vegas that's such a [__] good song I
agree is that Wayne Newton or is it
Elvis duh it's Elvis what does that song
remind you
of let me
think misong geniality oh for me it's
The
Flintstones also a great
reference The Flintstones are great
people they were hardworking family men
and women it's a story about family it's
a tale's oldest time it is and it's also
a story about you know the corporate
ladder if that's not the truth it's a
story
about facing adversity it's a Coming of
Age story yeah beautiful yeah and it
does remind me of The Flintstones it's
an amazing call why did they go to Las
Vegas again I don't know didn't they
like live in the Stone
Age literally in the Stone Age the FN
Stones right the stones of Flyn it was
called The Flintstones not the Flint
Vegas was one of the worst jokes also
another song about
Vegas shut up and put your money where
your mouth is that's what you get for
Waking Up in Vegas but also that new
Taylor Swift lyric dancing like a Vegas
acrobat it's not really like a song
about Vegas it's just a lyric that me
Karma Vibe like that
Spider Boy king of thi we little webs
over P Shark Boy Lava Girl love that
just fixed it fixed it for you
Tay all right that's our show thank you
so much for listening to the toast
millenni Morning Show where we Del with
the Fast Five story was our episode
every Monday through Friday on YouTube
so if you're watching us on YouTube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as podcast anywhere podcast
can be found so Spotify iTunes Stitch
public radio I radi cast box all the
places whoever you listen to podcast
find us the toes leave if I starve you
[__] about how beautiful stunning and
wickedly talented we are hope you'd have
an amazing day we'll see you tomorrow
but you won't see
us you won't see
us you will not
see
us love you bye bye